.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Für mich ist es ein Problem.
Ich sage Ihnen auch: Es stinkt.
Und Sie wissen immer,
dass es die Schweine sind?
Wenn es Sie so sehr stört,
können Sie ja gehen. - Nein, nein.
Ich bin hier aufgewachsen.
Das ist mein Zuhause.
Ich war vor den Schweinen hier
und gehe nicht deswegen weg.
* Vielstimmiges Grunzen *
Fünfmal mehr Schweine als Menschen -
willkommen
im luzernischen Hohenrain.
Dicke Luft im sog. Schweinegürtel.
Mich stört auch,
dass bei diesem Geruchsprojekt,
bei dem es eigentlich um ein von
Bauern verursachtes Problem geht ...
* Er atmet tief durch die Nase ein. *
Der Bauernverband
leitet dieses Projekt.
Für mich ist das wie ein Fuchs,
der den Hühnerstall bewacht.
Krach auch unter den Bauern.
Ich musste dann doch sagen:
"Scheisse, bin ich
der Depp von Hohenrain?" -
um es geradeheraus zu sagen.
Es darf nicht sein,
dass 200 m weiter gewurstelt wird.
* Quiekende Schweine, ruhige Musik *
* Er atmet tief durch die Nase ein. *
Der Gestank ist ziemlich penetrant.
Es ist, als ob man mitten
unter diesen Tieren stehen würde,
in diesem Stall voller Mist.
Es ist einfach
ein sehr unangenehmer Geruch.
Hier ist die Scheune,
in der sich die Tiere befinden.
In diesem Haus
wohnten wir vorher 25 Jahre lang.
Es steht
ungefähr 40 m vom Stall entfernt.
Wie kommt es, dass Sie
so nah an einem Schweinestall wohnen?
Als wir das Haus bauten,
war diese Scheune ein Viehstall
ausschliesslich mit Kühen -
etwa 12-15 Stück.
Erstens
ist das viel weniger intensiv
und zweitens stinken sie
auch nicht so sehr wie Schweine.
Vor 25 Jahren aber
kamen die Schweine,
und seither leide er unter
dem Gestank, sagt Markus Ineichen.
Wieso haben Sie sich nie beschwert?
Die Schweine
kamen ja in den 90er-Jahren.
Oh, wir haben uns oft beschwert.
Wir blitzten einfach zigmal ab.
Man vertröstete uns.
Einige der Beschwerden
wurden nicht einmal beantwortet.
Also von der Gemeinde?
- Ja.
Wir beschwerten uns
bei der Gemeinde,
und die sagte,
sie sei nicht zuständig,
sondern das Umweltschutz- oder
das Landwirtschaftsamt des Kanton.
Wir gingen dorthin, und die sagten,
das gehe sie nichts an.
Wir müssten zur Gemeinde gehen.
Wir wurden hin- und hergeschoben.
Also der Schwarze Peter ...
- Genau, der ging hin und her.
* Glockige Musik, Grunzen *
Schweinegestank in Hohenrain -
ein ungelöstes Problem.
Alle hier wissen es,
und sie wissen es seit Jahrzehnten.
Erst vor drei Jahren aber
reagierte die Politik.
Jetzt macht Annemarie Ineichen
beim sog.
Ressourcenprojekt Geruch mit -
einer schweizweiten Premiere.
Der grösste Teil dieses Projekts
wird durch nationale Steuergelder
finanziert.
Fast 1,2 Mio.
sind für acht Jahre budgetiert.
Die Gemeinde Hohenrain
organisiert regelmässige Treffen
mit Bauern und Anwohnern.
Heute sind nur die Anwohner dabei.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Hallo, Alfons. Ich bin zu spät.
Alles gut, wir haben Zeit.
- Sicher?
Hallo, Annemarie.
- Hallo, Reto.
Reto Berthel vertritt
die Anwohner seiner Siedlung.
Sibille Jenni von
der Umweltberatungsfirma Agrofutura
und eine Vertreterin der Hochschule
für Agrarwissenschaften
begleiten das Projekt.
Herzlich willkommen
zur heutigen Besprechung.
* Klopfen *
Wir haben ja ... schon viel getan.
Gemeindepräsident Alfons Knüsel
hat 15 Bauernhöfe besucht.
Der Wasserkurier.
Sie alle liegen
in der Nähe der Wohnzonen
von Annemarie Ineichen
und Reto Berthel.
Wir haben in Workshops
mit der Landwirtschaft
und unserer Projektgruppe
Massnahmen diskutiert.
Wir haben
die Abluftreinigungsanlagen geprüft,
die seit Jahren im Einsatz stehen.
Dort mussten Optimierungen
umgesetzt werden
oder werden noch umgesetzt.
Zwei Anlagen
werden bis Frühling 2023 ersetzt.
Dieser Prozess läuft.
Das ist eine der beiden
Luftreinigungsanlagen. Baujahr 2007.
Ob er je funktioniert hat,
ist unklar.
Neue Messungen jedenfalls zeigen:
Der Grenzwert
wird stark überschritten.
In den
setzten wir grosse Hoffnungen.
Im Nachhinein merkten wir aber,
dass das Marke Eigenbau war,
die weder vom Kanton
noch der Gemeinde
jemals geprüft
und abgenommen worden war.
Nein, das tat man nicht, weil man
diesen Anlagebauern glaubte.
Man glaubte, dass das besser ist.
Und es gab auch
eine deutliche Verbesserung damals,
als diese Anlagen
installiert wurden.
In den ersten Jahren, so stelle ich
es mir vor, gab es wieder Ruhe.
(Annemarie) War es so?
- Das nehme ich an.
Bei uns war es anders.
Es wurde von Anfang an
protokolliert,
dass die Gemeinde glaubte, dass
das funktioniert, aber wir nicht,
weil es gar keine Verbesserung gab.
Wir verlangten mehrmals -
auch das ist dokumentiert -
ein Abnahmeprotokoll
oder ein Zertifikat.
Aber wir bekamen keine Antwort.
Wir erhielten nie etwas.
Es passierte gar nichts.
Das war für uns etwas schwierig.
Die Behörden
haben das Gesetz nicht vollzogen.
Schon damals hätten sie die
Luftreiniger kontrollieren sollen.
Ich kann das nicht beurteilen.
Das war vor meiner Zeit.
Ich kann nur sagen,
dass wir während meiner Amtszeit
Massnahmen eingeleitet haben
und sehr viel passiert ist.
Ist die Bauernlobby
hier in Hohenrain stark?
Wir kommen schon aus ...
Wir sind eine Bauerngemeinde.
Wir haben diese Geschichte.
Die Schweineproduktion
im Kanton Luzern.
Ausser den Bauern gibt es
eine ganze Industrie an Futtermühlen,
Firmen, die Ställe bauen,
Schweinetransporteure,
Lastwagen, die Schweinegülle
im Kanton und ausserhalb verteilen,
und Schlachthöfe.
Jedes dritte Schwein in der Schweiz
wird im Kanton Luzern produziert.
Prima,
dann übergebe ich an dich, Reto.
Wir sind gespannt,
was Hohenrain und Günikon sagen.
Für uns in der Landschau hat sich
in Bezug auf die Geruchsemissionen,
was den Aufwind betrifft,
überhaupt nichts verändert.
Es stinkt genau gleich.
Die Abluftreinigungsanlagen -
das ist eine interne Angelegenheit -
entfernen
die Gerüche der Ausläufe nicht.
Wenn Nord- oder Nordwestwind
über die Ausläufe weht,
treibt das zu uns hoch.
Die sog. Ausläufe. Viele Bauern
halten ihre Schweine im Freien.
Was gut für die Tiere ist, verstärkt
den Geruch für die Anwohner.
* Er atmet tief durch die Nase ein. *
Der pensionierte Jurist
Reto Berthel sagt,
von diesem Stall wehten
die üblen Gerüche zu seiner Siedlung.
* Abwartende Musik *
Hallo?
Herr Anderhub?
- Ja.
Mein Name ist Berthel.
Guten Tag, Herr Anderhub.
Danke,
dass ich auf Ihren Hof kommen darf.
Die Luftreiniger
reinigen nur die Luft im Stall.
Im Freien wirken sie kaum.
Das sind diese Ausläufe, die ...
Also, die freien Ausläufe, mit denen
wir in der Landschau Probleme haben.
Wie sieht das bei Ihnen aus und wie
sind diese Ausläufe konzipiert?
Wir hatten davor ...
Hier sind drei Kanäle.
Hier hatten wir Festboden.
- Ja.
Den haben wir letzten Winter ent-
fernt und Vollspalten installiert,
damit nichts Flüssiges rumliegt.
- Ja.
Das Flüssige geht nach unten.
Walter Anderhubs kleiner Beitrag
zum Geruchsprojekt.
Beim Kot hapert es mit dem Abfluss,
und mehr will der Bauer nicht machen.
Ich sage einfach: Diese
freien Ausläufe sind ein Problem.
Sie sind wirklich ein Problem.
- Das ist allgemein so.
Warum schliessen Sie
die Ausläufe nicht, Herr Anderhub?
Erstens ist das teuer
und zweitens wegen der Beiträge.
Für das Tierwohl. - Wie viel
würde es kosten, sie zu schliessen?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Grob geschätzt vielleicht 300'000.
Und man kann schon sagen:
"Dach drüber und gut ist",
aber ob der Stall
dann noch funktioniert?
Sie sind nicht bereit, das
aus eigener Tasche zu finanzieren?
Nein, heute und morgen nicht.
Sie würden es ohne Zwang
also nicht tun?
Das Geruchsprojekt setzt auf
freiwillige Massnahmen der Bauern.
Laut Gesetz aber reicht das nicht,
denn die Geruchsbelastung
in Hohenrain ist übermässig.
Das beweist
eine wissenschaftliche Erhebung,
auf der das Projekt basiert.
Sog. Schnüffler zogen während
sechs Monaten durch die Wohnzonen
und führten Protokoll
über die Gerüche.
Sie nahmen
den Geruch der Landwirtschaft
während mehr als 10 %
der gemessenen Zeit wahr.
Damit gilt er als übermässig.
Die Messungen stammen
von der Berner Umweltfirma ecolot.
Sie setzt
ortsfremde Probandinnen ein.
Co-Geschäftsführer Luzi Bergamin
sagt:
Werden Gerüche
als übermässig eingestuft,
muss der Kanton
Massnahmen durchsetzen.
Es gibt klare gesetzliche Hebel, mit
denen man diese Bauern zwingen kann.
Ist ein einzelner Bauer verant-
wortlich, ist das relativ einfach.
Sind es mehrere,
ist es komplizierter.
Einfache Massnahmen
seitens der Bauern
sind geschlossene Ausläufe
und Luftreinigungsanlagen.
Ein Bauer sagt:
"Wenn ich den Aussenbereich
überdachen oder schliessen muss,
kostet mich das 300'000 Fr."
"Das kann ich mir nicht leisten."
Ich verstehe, dass das
für einen Bauern viel Geld ist.
Wenn aber nachgewiesen wird,
dass Immissionen übermässig sind,
gelten solche wirtschaftlichen
Kriterien nicht mehr absolut.
Und das ist in Hohenrain der Fall?
- Ja.
An der Sitzung in Hohenrain
kritisiert Reto Berthel,
das freiwillige Geruchsprojekt
sei zahnlos.
Ich werde immer gefragt,
was diese ganze Aktion hier kostet.
"Was kassiert ihr dabei?"
Ich kassiere gar nichts, Annemarie
auch nicht - das weiss ich.
Von den sonstigen Finanzen
habe ich aber null Ahnung.
Ich weiss nicht, was da ist.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie dieses Projekt finanziert wird
oder wie viel der Steuerzahler
von Hohenrain bezahlen muss.
Budgetiert sind
fast 1,2 Mio. für acht Jahre.
Ein Teil davon soll
an die Bauern ausgezahlt werden -
für Massnahmen,
die den Gestank vermindern.
Wenn ich mir das alles so ansehe,
komme ich ...
Das ist meine persönliche Meinung.
Von mir aus gesehen mangelt es
an einer klaren Zielvereinbarung,
es fehlt ein klares Konzept,
es mangelt an Transparenz
und an Professionalität.
Besten Dank.
Das war eine geballte Ladung.
Wir arbeiten daran,
gemeinsam und auf freiwilliger Basis
Lösungen zu finden
und Verbesserungen zu erzielen.
Ich glaube, das ist,
was wir jetzt fördern wollen.
Das führt zu früheren Massnahmen,
als wenn wir den rechtlichen Weg
eröffnen würden.
Dann hätten wir vielleicht in
zehn Jahren einen Vollzugsentscheid.
Darum wollen wir weiterhin
auf freiwilliger Basis
auf Augenhöhe und in einem guten Ton
zusammen mit der Bevölkerung und
der Landwirtschaft Lösungen finden.
Wir wollen auch wieder stolz
auf unsere Landwirtschaft sein.
Das hat in letzter Zeit gelitten.
Aber das Umweltschutzgesetz
ist kein Wunschprogramm.
Der Kanton
müsste die Bauern verpflichten,
den übermässigen Gestank
zu vermindern.
Warum tut das der Vorsteher
des Luzerner Umweltamts nicht?
Wenn man sich heute
das Kantonsparlament ansieht,
ist das natürlich ...
Es gibt eine sehr starke Lobby,
die natürlich sagt ...
Die Bauernlobby?
- ... wo's langgeht.
Es ist einfach schwer,
das umzusetzen.
Ja.
- Das Gesetz?
Das Umweltgesetz?
- Der Vollzug, ja.
Wegen der Bauernlobby, richtig?
Ja, es ist ... Es ist schwierig.
In der Vergangenheit
wurde das ja alles ...
Man sagte, man wolle die Bauern
stärken und die Tierhaltung fördern.
Jetzt kommen diese Umweltaspekte
und Klimathemen -
jetzt ist ein Sinneswandel nötig.
Wir befinden uns da mittendrin.
Ist es für Sie in diesem Kanton auch
nicht immer ganz leicht? - Natürlich.
Es ist ... Ich will manchmal ...
Fachlich und vom Vollzug her
würde ich gerne
schneller vorwärtsmachen können,
aber das ist nicht immer möglich.
In der Windrichtung von Schweinen
mit freiem Auslauf:
die Siedlung Landschau und auch
das Eigenheim von Reto Berthel.
* Er atmet tief durch die Nase ein. *
Früher leitete der Jurist
das Handelsregisteramt in Luzern.
* Helles Klingeln *
Jetzt hat er sich das Geruchsprojekt
zum heiligen Auftrag gemacht.
Und so kommt es, dass Reto Berthel
weitere Regelverstösse
in der Landwirtschaft entdeckt hat.
Meine Abklärungen haben ergeben,
dass
beim Landwirtschaftsbetrieb Anderhub
ein Silo einfach ...
... in diesem Sinne ...
... abgerissen wurde.
Und hier hinten wurde ein neues,
grösseres Silo gebaut.
Und zwar, ohne dass der Bauer
eine Bewilligung eingeholt hätte.
Reto Berthel
meldete ihn bei der Gemeinde.
Das kann in unserem Staat
doch nicht die Situation sein.
Wofür haben wir denn Behörden?
Ich als Pensionierter
muss hier die Aufsicht machen,
damit das alles
durchgeführt werden kann?
Da kann ich mir nur
an den Kopf fassen und sagen:
"So geht es einfach nicht."
Was mich eigentlich antreibt,
ist nicht ...
Ich kann nichts tun.
Diese Untätigkeit, nichts verändern
zu können - das ist mein Problem.
Wenn Kritiker, vielleicht sogar
jemand aus der Landschau,
sagen würde: "Herr Berthel ist doch
einfach so ein Buchhalter Nötzli."?
Das ist sein gutes Recht.
Das kann er machen.
Vielleicht stimmt es auch -
ich weiss es nicht.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass ich Buchhalter Nötzli bin -
schon vom Temperament her nicht.
Hier in den Gemeindenachrichten
ist da ein Bild,
auf dem man saubere Schweine sieht.
Das ist der Idealfall.
Ich ging dem nach
und musste dann feststellen,
dass die Realität
ganz anders aussieht.
Ich habe hier Fotos davon,
wie es in der Realität aussieht.
(Annemarie) Die Fotos machtest du?
- Darauf komme ich noch.
Mit diesem Stall stimmt etwas nicht,
wie Reto Berthel später
von einem anderen Bauern erfährt.
Die Situation sei aber heikel.
Ich will einfach nicht,
dass das eskaliert.
Ja, ja.
- Der Bauer ...
Ja, Reto, wir gehen nun
auf den Stall des Betreibers zu,
dessen Verhalten mich stört.
Er hat die bestehenden Ausläufe
und Buchten völlig abgeändert.
Er hat sie weiter geöffnet.
Dort vorne wurde aufgefräst,
und die Türen wurden entfernt.
Wenn das kontinuierlich offen ist,
ist das Problem natürlich,
dass man den Geruch nicht mit
der Reinigungsanlage auffangen kann.
Der kommt ja raus.
Und hier sieht man auch,
wie die Schweine im Dreck liegen.
Dieser Stall
war einmal anders konzipiert.
Die Ausläufe mit dem Futter
waren draussen.
Jetzt wurde er verändert.
Wenn man so etwas abändert,
verrichten die Schweine ihr Geschäft
manchmal nicht am richtigen Ort.
Pikanterweise ist dieser Bauer
ein Vertreter im Geruchsprojekt -
ein Botschafter, sozusagen.
Er hat uns erlaubt,
auf seinem Grundstück zu drehen.
Seinen Stall
hat er zum Projektstart umgebaut -
damals ohne Baubewilligung,
also illegal.
Dass er hier
Dinge herausgerissen hatte,
flog vor zwei Jahren bei einem
Drohnenflug für TV-Aufnahmen auf.
Sonst gäbe es wohl
noch heute kein Baugesuch.
Aufgrund dieser Aufnahmen
wurde der Bauer denunziert.
Erst danach wurde die Gemeinde aktiv
und verlangte rückwirkend
ein Baugesuch.
Die Gemeinde merkte das nicht selbst?
Wahrscheinlich schauen
Kanton und Gemeinde so lange zu
und lassen so lange Goodwill
spielen, wie's geht,
um Lösungen zu finden.
Aber wenn man Dinge sieht,
die wirklich illegal gebaut wurden
und die einen Einfluss
auf die Bevölkerung haben,
kann man nicht lange zusehen.
Das geht nicht.
Ich bedauere das.
Ich habe auch erfahren,
dass es keine gesetzlichen Fristen
in diesem Sinne gibt.
Das liegt im Ermessen
des Raumplanungs- und unseres Amtes.
Auch die Gemeinde
kann das selbst ...
Wenn sie Kenntnis davon hat ...
- Es gibt keine Fristen?
Das kann zwei Jahre so gehen?
- Das ist einfach ...
Gut,
wir haben jetzt eine Frist gesetzt.
Jetzt wird das bereinigt.
Das ist das Wesentliche.
Also nach zwei Jahren.
- Ja, das ist unschön.
Das ist so. Ich würde es
auch gerne anders sehen.
Ist das Amt
auch ein wenig überlastet?
Es hat sicher auch damit zu tun,
dass es sehr viele Baugesuche gibt.
Das führt natürlich auch
zu einer Überlastung.
Arthur Röösli
ist der einzige Bauer in Hohenrain,
der mit gutem Beispiel
vorangegangen ist
und als Folge des Geruchsprojekts
eine neue Luftreinigung
installiert hat.
Kann ich reingehen?
- Ja.
Gut.
- Also.
Sag mir doch mal,
wonach es hier drin riecht.
Ich stelle fest, dass es hier drin
nicht nach Schweinen riecht.
Es ist feucht. Es riecht nach Erde,
aber sehr angenehm.
Wie Waldboden, nicht?
- Ja, so in der Art.
Hier drin wird die Luft
durch Bakterien vom Geruch befreit -
bis zu 80 % laut Hersteller.
Gleichzeitig wird sie auch
von Ammoniak befreit,
zwischen 70 und 90 %.
Es ist sehr wichtig, dass das
Ammoniak nicht mehr oben rausgeht,
denn die Säure im Ammoniak
kann Moore und Wälder schädigen.
250'000 habe die Anlage gekostet.
Die Gemeinde versprach ihm
einen Beitrag von 50'000 Fr.,
auch wegen anderer Massnahmen
gegen den Geruch.
Wer neben der Wohnzone
eine neue Luftreinigung installiert,
hat heute wegen der Schweinegülle
strengere Auflagen.
Ausläufe im Freien
müssen geschlossen werden.
Arthur Röösli sagt,
er verliere darum 12'000 Fr.
an Beiträgen fürs Tierwohl pro Jahr.
Ich muss das
aufgrund des Baugesuchs schliessen.
Da habe ich mir selbst
ins Bein geschossen.
Die anderen
tun es wohl deswegen nicht,
weil sie die Ausläufe schliessen
müssten - das wäre das Ende.
Herr Berthel, was sagen Sie dazu?
Weil Nachbarn wie Sie ein Problem
mit Herrn Rööslis Gestank haben,
geht es den Schweinen
künftig schlechter.
Es ist schlechter fürs Tierwohl,
wenn sie im Stall bleiben müssen.
Und Herr Röösli
verliert sogar Einnahmen.
Ich sehe schon,
dass das ein Problem ist,
aber es gibt in jeder Berufsgattung
gewisse Risiken.
Wenn Sie etwas tun,
müssen Sie darüber nachdenken,
welche Konsequenzen es hat.
Und wenn ich die Konsequenzen kenne,
muss ich entscheiden,
ob ich es durchziehe.
Da muss ich dir recht geben.
Der Bauherr baut auf eigenes Risiko.
Wenn es im Nachgang
mehr Immissionen gibt
und sich ein erheblicher Teil
der Bevölkerung daran stört,
muss man weitere Massnahmen treffen.
Das steht in jeder Baubewilligung.
So sichern sich Kanton und Gemeinde
als Baubewilligungsbehörden ab.
Drei Monate
nach Beginn unserer Aufnahmen
spitzt sich die Situation zu.
Hallo, Alfons.
Arthur Röösli ist an eine Sitzung
des Geruchsprojekts eingeladen.
Diesmal treffen sich die Anwohner
mit den Bauern.
Auch der Bauer, der seinen Stall ohne
Bewilligung umgebaut hat, ist dabei.
Er sei so beraten worden, sagt er.
Im Nachhinein verbietet er uns,
seinen Namen und seine Aussagen
zu verwenden.
Ich habe in den letzten
zwei, drei Monaten erfahren,
dass in Hohenrain wieder
Dinge laufen - auch vorher schon -,
die mich stinksauer machen.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Es geht nicht, dass ich seit zwei
Jahren an diesem Projekt arbeite
und ein Nachbar gleichzeitig
seinen Stall weiter öffnet.
Da darf ich dich ansprechen.
Darunter werden wieder ohne
Baubewilligung Ausläufe abgeändert.
Da frage ich mich, warum ich
für jeden kleinen Mückenschiss
ein Baugesuch
und eine Bewilligung brauche,
weil es sonst "Bumm" macht.
Da musste ich dann doch sagen:
"Scheisse,
bin ich der Depp von Hohenrain?" -
um es geradeheraus zu sagen.
So komme ich mir momentan vor.
Ich habe alles sauber so gemacht,
wie man es haben will.
Es darf nicht sein,
dass 200 m weiter gewurstelt wird.
Ich muss letztlich
meinen Hof schützen.
Ich kann nicht einfach sagen:
"Ist ja egal."
Ich habe 250'000 investiert,
und auf anderen Betrieben
läuft's weiter wie vor 20 Jahren.
Das darf nicht mehr sein.
Ich appelliere
ans Ressourcenprojekt,
dass man an gewissen Orten mal
den Nagel einschlägt.
Der betroffene Bauer sagt,
er wolle seinen Stall sowieso
zu einem Rinderstall umbauen.
Rinder stinken weniger.
Ist das verbindlich?
Die Schweinemast dort ist erledigt.
Dort entsteht eine Rindermast.
Ist das richtig?
Verbindlich sei gar nichts,
antwortet der Bauer.
Es komme auf die Marktlage
und die Baupreise an.
Es könnte also sein, dass
dein Gesuch u.U. zurückgezogen wird
und die aktuelle Situation
Status quo bleibt?
Das sei möglich, sagt der Bauer.
Drei Jahre lang
gab es eine Verschlimmbesserung
und damit eine unhaltbare Situation,
weil kein Baugesuch
eingereicht wurde.
Weil man davon ausging,
die Betriebsstruktur
werde relativ schnell geändert.
Drei Jahre?
- Ja.
Hm. Okay. Ob das schnell ist ...
Wir dachten,
es würde schneller gehen.
Sie sind also limitiert?
Wir sind limitiert, so ist es.
Was der Kanton entscheidet -
auch später, wenn das Projekt
abgeschlossen ist -,
können wir einfach noch nicht sagen.
Wer trägt eigentlich
die Verantwortung
für dieses nationale
1-Mio.-Projekt?
Der Luzerner
Bäuerinnen- und Bauernverband.
Die Bauernlobby schützt die Bauern -
da bewacht der Fuchs den Hühnerstall.
Das sehe ich nicht so.
Wir leiten dieses Projekt,
weil wir eine Lösung bringen wollen
und uns die Problematik bewusst ist.
Aber bislang sieht es danach aus,
als ob man mit Freiwilligkeit
keine Lösung schaffen würde.
Man kann uns
zumindest nicht vorwerfen,
wir hätten es nicht versucht.
Zumindest haben wir dann
einen Leitfaden dafür,
wie man es machen müsste,
damit es funktionieren kann.
1 Mio. für einen Leitfaden,
in dem steht, was man tun sollte?
Genau. Wenn man irgendwo scheitern
darf, dann ja wohl an einem Projekt.
* Sie atmen tief
durch die Nase ein. *
Seit dem Start des Geruchsprojekts
sind zwei Jahre vergangen.
Am Wohnort von Annemarie und Markus
Ineichen stinkt es aber wie zuvor.
Laut Projekt
sollte im Stall gegenüber
bis Ende April eine neue
Luftreinigung eingebaut sein,
aber es gibt noch nicht einmal
eine Baubewilligung.
Nachbar Urs Isenegger
hat zwar ein Baugesuch eingereicht,
aber der Kanton
hat es dreimal sistiert.
Der Bauer hat zu wenige und wider-
sprüchliche Unterlagen eingereicht.
Eigentlich fühle ich mich
zum heutigen Zeitpunkt verarscht.
Einerseits vom Bauherrn, der dieses
Projekt angehen und lösen müsste,
andererseits auch von den Behörden,
weil man so wenig hört
und als Direktbetroffener
eigentlich nie Gehör bekommt.
Man wird nicht ernst genommen.
- Ja.
Das ist etwas vom Schlimmsten.
Ja.
Er ist ja Stallplaner.
Für mich
ist es eine Verzögerungstaktik,
wenn man nichts einreicht,
was bewilligungsfähig ist.
Man müsste einfach etwas
Bewilligungsfähiges einreichen.
Verstehen Sie Nachbarn, die sagen,
Sie spielten nur auf Zeit?
Da verstehe ich
die Nachbarn eigentlich nicht.
Sie müssten vielleicht mal schauen,
wie schwierig es
in der Landwirtschaft ist,
eine Baubewilligung zu erhalten.
Ich bin ja in dieser Branche tätig.
Das kann bis zu drei Jahre dauern.
Der Kanton sagte Ihnen,
Sie hätten zu wenige
und falsche Unterlagen geliefert.
Wenn ich kontrolliere,
kann ich sagen,
ich hätte gerne
dies und jenes noch gesehen.
Es ist einfach
eine Verschärfung des Systems.
Vielleicht hat man zuvor
zu lasch oder gar nicht hingeschaut,
und jetzt
wurde der Spiess umgedreht.
Auch beim Bauern, der seinen Stall
ohne Bewilligung umgebaut hat,
herrscht immer noch der Status quo.
Der Kanton
hat aber kürzlich entschieden,
dass der veränderte Aussenbereich
rückgebaut
oder stillgelegt werden muss.
Und Reto Berthel,
der pensionierte Chefbeamte?
Hallo, Reto.
- Hallo, Thuri. Wie geht's?
Gut.
Er informiert Bauer Arthur Röösli
über seine neuesten Recherchen.
Die Leitung des Geruchsprojekts
habe Anwohner/-innen
zur aktuellen Situation
des Schweinegestanks interviewt.
Ganz interessant ist,
dass über diese Interviews
ein Bericht erstellt wurde.
Für mich ist in dieser Situation
entscheidend
und eigentlich befremdlich,
dass ich als Bevölkerungsvertreter
diesen Bericht offiziell
nicht einmal erhalten habe.
Ich würde die Resultate
nicht kennen,
wenn ich nicht von dritter Seite
ein Exemplar erhalten hätte.
Ist es immer noch übermässig?
Stört man sich am Geruch
oder ist das besser geworden?
Die Gerüche kommen meist schwall-
artig und sind nicht konstant.
Die Aussagen,
die hier gemacht werden,
sind meines Erachtens nichts Neues.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass es eine Veränderung gibt,
wenn ein Landwirtschaftsbetrieb
auf Rindermast umstellt.
Meinst du, das kommt?
Ich frage ganz kritisch.
Da führt man doch die Behörden,
die Anwohner und alle zusammen
an der Nase rum. Entschuldige.
So gewinnt man natürlich
Zeit ohne Ende.
Das ist, von mir aus gesehen,
alles Lausbubenkram.
Mit dem Ressourcenprojekt
hat man es in den Händen.
Da werden Leute
von Bund und Kanton gut bezahlt,
um dieses Ressourcenprojekt
durchzuführen.
Aber für mich ist das
zum Scheitern verurteilt.
In der Phase, in der es jetzt ist,
ist es zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Demnächst wird die Bevölkerung
über das Geruchsprojekt informiert.
Das Ganze wird einfach schöngeredet.
Es wird nichts laufen.
Darum komme ich dem zuvor und will,
dass die Bevölkerung
darüber informiert wird,
was hier eigentlich gespielt wird.
Was glaubst du,
wie die reagieren werden?
Die werden mich verfluchen.
Ich glaube,
ich gehe dann irgendwo anders hin.
Sie werden mich in alle
Himmelsrichtungen verfluchen,
aber das ist mir wurst.
- Da bist du nicht der Einzige.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
M. Gassner, D. McMinn - 2023